unter meinem letzten reaktion video auf
die rtl2 serie hilft mir wurde mir
zahlreich in die kommentare geschrieben
luca reagiere auf die folge mein freund
mästet mich ja heute werden wieder paar
gehirnzellen vernichtet
[Musik]
auf was habe
mich hier wieder eingelassen was hat er
denn gebracht hat ihn nackt auf sofa
gelegt und sich süßigkeiten auf dem
bauch geparkt hat jedoch alles für mein
tun um ein pummelchen hate münchen
nein
was ist mit dir pummelchen also ich
hatte verstehen denn die süßigkeiten
mögen et cetera pp aber so ist der
sollte nicht auf youtube sein
ich weiß schon worauf das hinausläuft
jeder der lesen kann hat die auf den
titel gesehen mein freund mästet mich
also anscheinend ist dieser junge der
dort nackt liegt der freund von diesem
mädchen namens komischen und er mästet
sie also er will dass sie immer mehr
frisst
ich könnte jetzt stell dir die liebe
frage weil sie nicht alle chips vor ihr
seid auch da essen willst dass ich noch
um gefallen ich muss das ja immer zu
beginn sagen wenn ich hier irgendwie nen
beleidige oder mich über irgendwen
kaputt lache dann geht es nicht gegen
die person persönlich sondern es geht
nur um die geschauspielert rolle und
dieser junge können echte netteste
mensch der welt sein ist wahrscheinlich
auch aber das ist einfach nur menschen
nicht gesund ziemlich abstoßend
du bist doch meine große liebe 1
[Musik]
sie sagte ihm sie würde alles für ihn
tun und er gibt ihr der bug um welche
die sie essen soll bald mit ihrer welt
seit ashley mit louis zusammen ist hat
sich die 19-jährige sehr verändert was
nicht nur auf begeisterung stößt ist das
gemeinste was war eine rinke dame fragen
kann also schauspielerisch ist das echt
so wie krieg
komplett scheiße sorry das thema stoppen
aber ich möchte nicht dass ihr komplett
verdummt werdet ich weiß nicht wieso ein
vorstellungsgespräch sage ich mal bei
der serie hilf mir abläuft aber
wahrscheinlich so hallo sie wollen ja
hier beihilfe mitspielen haben sie denn
schon erfahrung im schauspielerischen
bereich haben sie schon mal
geschauspielert haben sie da vielleicht
eine ausbildung gemacht alles klar sie
sind eingestellt jeder kann einfach
nicht fassen also das ist ja das sieht
nach einer ausgewogenen ernährung aus
ach du scheiße das militär sich ashley
verändert hat
ich bin immer an so pumpen wo ich mir
denke hey das ist gerade krass die frist
von ihrem freund darunter und dann kommt
diese schauspielerische leistung die
komplette den keller geht und dann kommt
wieder eine szene wie sowas wo ich mir
dann wirklich einfach nur denke ich mal
ganz gut gegen die bühne werfen
vernünftiges essen war plötzlich einfach
etwas dickere frauen liebt
dann ist es doch völlig normal dass mir
den gefallen oder nicht
es gibt in anderen beziehungen mit
anderen beziehung meine ich 100% anderer
beziehungen eigentlich in die andere
richtung
da freut man sich wenn der partner sich
gesund ernährt und auf seine ernährung
achtet und dann gehts pummelchen die
frist dann auch gern mal einen schoko
keks mit sahne
da muss ich dir recht geben die tante
hier kamen wirklich einfach an und hat
noch kein positives wort über das
pummelchen hier gesagt was ist
eigentlich recht annahme ich glaube erst
die und endlich kann ich auf jeden fall
verstehen also wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise besuch bekommen würde von
einem alten schulfreund von ich hatte
die freunde von daher kann ich das doch
nicht so ganz nachvollziehen
die danken und zu mussten ich finde es
herrlich ab
das wieder dieser punkt weiß wissen wo
ich dachte es geht nicht krasser
kommt so was dann noch am späten
nachmittag ist genervt
die sich genervt die ist pizza miras
verhalten macht ihr schwer zu schaffen
da hilft nur eines frustessen jetzt war
vor dem essen abgesehen bin ich auch
sehr sehr starke wie das wohnzimmer bei
denen eingerichtet ist
da steht einfach ein stuhl einkaufen
oder einkaufen
man fand ihn die heißt wieder zutritt in
der stadt
ich habe also ich jetzt mal ganz anders
gesehen jetzt mal nicht irgendwie zu
dieser serie an sich und das was alles
schon lustig ist und so weiter und so
fort aber mir tun die leute auch recht
ein bisschen leid weil ich bin ganz
ehrlich wenn man dort so eine rolle
annimmt
dann hat man ja echt sehr krasse
finanzielle nöte denke ich mal deswegen
möchte ich mich auf jeden fall an der
stelle schon mal entschuldigen falls
sich irgendjemand der schauspieler dort
persönlich angegriffen gefühlt bitte
versteht wirklich dass es gegen diese
gespielte rolle geht und wenn ich was
gegen spongebob sage dann meine ich auch
nicht den synchronsprecher es war ein
komplett dummes beispiel luca match wie
kann die denn nur damit genau das
richtige in der bayer mit wieder mittel
an ein schoko macht einfach auf das ist
der beste schütze und alle sorgen wieder
futsch
das macht mich ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen traurig
wie ich mein geld verdiene ach du
scheiße können hier
ich weiß doch was dein promising
glücklich macht die waage soll endlich
gewissheit bringen
jetzt wird's spannend schreibt jetzt mal
die kommentare was ihr denkt wie viel
sie wiegen wird
[Musik]
74 so viel gegessen glaubt anscheinend
ja nicht so als hätten wir das ergebnis
jetzt nicht auf der waage du bist du
musst mir glauben bewegt sich einfach
dafür das ist das problem
drei stunden später luis erfreut sich am
anblick seiner traumfrauen
ist hier dieser punkt bisher also wie es
geht einfach nicht ich kann das ich kann
es nicht in worte fassen was ich gerade
empfinde für ihn gilt je dicker desto
besser
bisher macht eure reaktion allein dort
freunde da bin ich wieder zurück was
geht hier was machst du denn hier
du sollst dich doch nicht bewegen so
wird das doch nie war hatte ich gehe
wieder da bin ich wieder freuen ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich bin mal kurz
rausgegangen eine frische luft haben
müssen durchgeatmet weil das spielt ja
auch mit meiner gesundheit diese folge
sagte freude
mindestens 20 kennst du du versprichst
verständlich dass du zumindest aber das
passiert nicht so wie vorher gesehen
haben muss und ich ziehen sobald man die
helfende sechs tore machst du sowieso
das frage ich mich wirklich ob du mich
liebst
ich will ganz ehrlich gesagt einfach nur
sterben vielleicht nicht die anderen
frauen aber lieber einzeln wieder größer
geworden aber das sind natürlich nicht
wenn du nur die schönen bilder an stars
ehrlich jetzt hat die schönste
überraschung gelungen heute gemacht hast
ich liebe dich da bin ich wieder zurück
freut
[Musik]
wir werden für immer zusammen leute ich
bin ganz ehrlich das video geht noch
zweieinhalb minuten aber es wäre vorbei
der abfahrt hat sich der wettbewerb
mache das nicht mehr mit meiner
gesundheit leidet unter mir ich muss
dass ihr beenden
es tut mir leid aber ich muss mir jetzt
therapeuten suchen
[Musik]